Європа - це вільна торгівля, вільне право
пересування. Толерантність, чесніть.
Для мене Європа - це частина світу, яка завжди веде людство вперед,
створює поняття гуманізму..
Об’єднання країн, які
підтримують один одного в складних ситуаціях.
Я більше Європу сприймаю духовно, ніж
територіально, чи якось політично.
Європа для мене - як певний ідеал кращого життя.
Напередодні виборів до Європарламенту DW вирішила
запитати українських школярів, що вони знають про ЄС
і що для них означає бути частиною Європи.
У Голосіївському ліцеї Києва ми потрапили на перший
відкритий всеукраїнський онлайн-урок "Європа починається з тебе".
Інтерактивне спілкування, соціальні ролики.
Мета заняття - дати дітям необхідну інформацію для розуміння того,
що таке об'єднана Європа і місце України в цій Європі.
В Європі дуже добре розвинута освіта
і дуже добре дбають про пенсіонерів.
Це було б дуже непогано, якби наші пенсіонери
також мали такі ж великі пенсії.
Якщо ми говоримо про українську Європу -
це коли український народ працює на свою країну,
тобто вкладає гроші в казну своєї країни.
Я хотів би, щобнаша українська гривня стала більш стабільною і ближче до євро.
Висловлювати свої думки та розуміти те,
що людину не будуть дискримінувати за ці думки. Це свобода.
Старшокласники цього ліцею вважають, що Європа вже тут -
у їхніх серцях і навіть у їхній гімназії.
Тут не забороненовільно сидіти на цьому сучасному стадіоні
- як і в парках європейських міст,
які ці діти завдяки безвізовому режиму з ЄС
вже змогли відвідати. Вони помічають,
що Україна за останні п'ять років стала більш європейською країною.
Бути європейцем - це не викидати сміття, не давати хабарі...
Європа в 12 уроках.
З моменту підписання Угоди про асоціацію України з ЄС
в українських школах з'явилися такі підручники.
Реформується і сама школа.
Першокласники вже навчаються за програмою "Нова українська школа".
Оновили програму навчання для старшокласників.
З’явилися нові курси, приміром, курс громадянської освіти.
Це елемент євроінтеграції. Чому?
Бо діти висловлюютьсвої побажання, як поліпшити
свій навчальний процес, освітній,
що треба зробити в нашому навчальному закладі.
П’ятикласники Степан та Поліна саме такі.
Вони відчувають себе обізнаними європейцями.
Адже вже відвідували деякі країни ЄС разом з класом і батьками.
Старі будинки там зносити не можна,
повинно бути так, якраніше.
І не так, що дав хабаря - і можеш тут зносити і будувати собі.
Мені б дуже хотілося, щоб люди,
які брали тварин або з притулку, або з магазину,
апотім викидали, щоб їм за це робили штрафи.
Старшокласники цікавляться європейською політикою,
дискутують про це і стежать
за теперішніми виборами до Європарламенту.
Адже від того, яким буде новий склад Європарламенту,
певною мірою залежатимуть і стосунки ЄС з Україною.
Попри більшу, напевно, присутність більш популістичних сил,
все ж таки більшість, яка є євроцентристською,
а відповідно є і проукраїнською одночасно,
проукраїнською з точки зору України, яка є демократичною, яка розвивається,  яка змінюється,
вона буде збережена. Це буде напевно складніший парламент для України.
Зрештою політика політикою, а бажання людей
і в Євросоюзі, і в Україні одні і ті ж:
Я хочу бачити на вулицях щасливі обличчя людей.
На думку п’ятикласника Марата, безвіз дасть можливість
більшій кількості українців побувати в Європі
і на власні очі побачити і, можливо, навчитися,
як прості буденні речі
можуть кардинально змінити і людей, і країну.